veamos cuántas veces entra o cabe 16 en
1.388 y primero en lo que quiero pensar
es en como tradicionalmente se resuelven
este tipo de problemas y luego nos vamos
a poder introducir en un nuevo método
que nos va a permitir hacer más como
aproximaciones por pedazos entonces
comúnmente vemos prime el primer dígito
de nuestra entrada de la división y
vemos que 16 no caben y una vez en el 1
luego nos fijamos en el 13
en el siguiente dígito y tampoco cabe 16
ninguna vez en el 13 y entonces vamos a
hacer una operación para ver cuántas
veces cabe 16 en 138 entonces vamos a
ver cuánto nos da 16 por 9 por decir
algún número entonces 6 por 9 son 54
acarreamos 59 por una es 9 y 5 que
llevábamos 14 entonces esta primera
operación nos da 144 pero vemos que se
pasa de 138 entonces seguramente si
multiplicamos 16 por 8 nos vamos a estar
aproximando sin pasarnos
a nuestro número que queremos llegar que
es el 138 entonces ahora vemos 6 por 8
es 48 decimos que llevamos 4 o
acarreamos 4 luego 8 por una es 8 4 son
12 entonces finalmente tenemos que 16
por 828 y restamos al número que
queramos llegar nuestros 128 entonces
finalmente nuestro residuo es 10 y ahora
nos queda un dígito más por aquí que
vamos a bajar y vamos a hacer el mismo
procedimiento vamos a borrar el 4 que
teníamos por arriba para no confundirnos
y una vez más nos preguntamos cuántas
veces cabe 16 en 108 pero resultará ser
demasiado evidente que 9 va a quedar muy
por arriba de nuestro resultado que
queremos 8 también quedaría por arriba
vamos a ver qué tal nos queda si
multiplicamos por 7 ya estoy haciendo mi
operación y luego 7 por una es 7 y 4 que
llevábamos es 11 entonces nos queda 112
vemos que también se quedaría pasando
el resultado al que queremos llegar
entonces seguro 6 no se pasa entonces
vamos a hacer nuestra operación con el
múltiplo de 6 bueno multiplicando 16 por
6 entonces 6 por 6 36 decimos que
llevamos 36 por 16 y 39 entonces ahora
le vamos a restar a 108 nuestro 96 8
menos 6 es 210 menos 9 es una y decimos
que tenemos un residuo de 12 finalmente
este número es más pequeño que 16
entonces sabemos que no cabe ninguna vez
dentro de 12 por lo que si quisiéramos
seguir nuestra operación tendríamos que
utilizar ya números decimales para
continuar pero vamos a detenernos hasta
aquí para tener un resultado entero y
vamos a decir que este va a ser nuestro
residuo y finalmente decimos que 16 cada
86 veces en 1.388 luego por el lado
derecho voy a hacer nuestro segundo
método
pero qué pasaría que lo que quisiéramos
es verlo desde otro modo quizás un poco
más interesante para resolverlo así que
una vez más nos vamos a preguntar
cuántas veces cada 16 en 1.388 y la
situación aquí es que hay demasiadas
maneras para poder hacer una
aproximación y finalmente llega a lo que
el problema está pidiendo y lo que
queremos hacer es ver cuántas veces cabe
dicho 16 dando estimaciones sin ir muy
lejos a lo que nos está pidiendo
entonces en esta ocasión voy a basar me
en algunos resultados previos para
después irlos utilizando en nuestro
avance del problema entonces decimos que
16 por 2 es 32 luego 16 por 5 nos da 80
entonces ahora sí vamos a resolver
nuestro problema
cuántas veces cabe 16 en 1.388 y bueno
para empezar a hacer algunos
acercamientos o aproximaciones sabemos
que si multiplicamos a 16% nuestro
resultado sería 1600 pues simplemente le
estamos sumando agregan
dos ceros a nuestro 16 pero vemos que
1600 queda muy por arriba del resultado
que queremos llegar entonces con nuestro
resultado previos sabemos que 16 por 5
es igual a 80 por lo que entonces si
multiplicamos 16 por 50 esto nos va a
dar 800 y 800 que da un poco más cerca
del resultado que queremos sin pasarse
entonces qué es lo que estamos haciendo
multiplicar 16 por 50 en lugar de 5 lo
estamos multiplicando por 50 y dicho
resultado nos va a dar 800 entonces lo
pondré en nuestro lado derecho para no
perdernos en los pasos vamos a utilizar
800 y ahora sí vamos a restarle a 1.388
los 800 que una vez más lo repito lo
calculamos al multiplicar 16 por 50
entonces 80 8 a -0 es 88 menos 0 es 8 y
13 - 8 es 5 entonces tenemos un residuo
de 588 y repetimos la pregunta
a veces cabe 16 en 588 y si te das
cuenta podemos volver a utilizar un
resultado previo que tenemos de nuestro
lado izquierdo sabemos que ya no puede
ser por 50 puesto que se pasaría de lo
que queremos llegar pero qué pasaría si
ahora en lugar de multiplicar 16 por 2
que nos da 20 digo que nos da 32
multiplicamos 16 por 20 que nos daría
320 y es un resultado muy bueno que se
aproxima a 588 y una vez más restamos
588 a 320 dicho residuo nos va a quedar
de 268 ahora veamos cuántas veces cabe
16 en 268 y bien pues el 800 ya nos
queda demasiado lejano a 268 luego 320
ahora también resulta ser grande para lo
que queremos llegar entonces podemos
decir que 10 veces 16 nos queda algo
cercano y simplemente no no nos estamos
alejando demasiado del resultado no
estamos siendo
pero estamos buscando una aproximación
buena que no se pase de lo que queremos
entonces finalmente lo que hicimos fue
multiplicar 16 por 10 nos queda 160 y le
restamos a 268 160 ahora al hacer esta
operación esta resta nos va a volver a
quedar un residuo de 108 y si recuerdas
cuando multiplicamos 16 por 5 nos daba
80 y no se pasa de 108 entonces 16 por 5
80 lo estoy usando con diferente color
para que se vea de una forma más
esquemática y nos restan 28 ahora quedan
más sencillo cuántas veces cabe 16 en 28
pues simplemente una y al restar la 28
16 nos queda finalmente un residuo de 12
el cual ya no cabe 16 ninguna vez en 12
por lo que podemos decir que hemos
finalizado y ahora tú me vas a preguntar
bueno y cómo voy a saber cuántas veces
cabe 16 en 1.388
es simple ahora lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sumar nuestros múltiplos que
utilizamos de nuestro lado derecho vamos
a sumar 50 + 20 que son 70 + 10 85 85
más 1 nos queda 86 y un residuo de 12
ahora si la pregunta sería cuál es lo
padre de irlo realizando con este método
a mí me parece bastante interesante
porque simplemente vas tomando como
pequeños trozos de números enteros que
te van aproximando al resultado original
en el primer paso lo que nosotros
hicimos fue tomar 800 crear un resultado
previo y se lo restamos le restamos a
1300 88 800 y fuimos trabajando con otro
pequeño pedazo aproximándonos al
resultado espero te resulte demasiado
interesante